Once you have a simple version of your
game, you'll want to test it out.
But how did developers start testing?
>> Many developers give their game
to their friends and family to play.
And once they have
a more polished version,
they deploy it to an app store to get
reviews from a much wider audience.
>> But
only some players submit reviews and
it takes a while to read through them.
Is there a quicker way to get feedback?
>> Actually, yes.
Many developers use analytics tools,
like Amazon Mobile Analytics, which
tracks app usage and revenue over all
your users without any player reviews.
These tools help you identify
where players stop playing,
when they buy in app items, and
what games are most popular.
>> So don't be afraid to submit
a game with a few imperfections,
analytics can help you identify any
flaws and strengths early on and
regular updates can help you create
the best ongoing experience for players.
>> Next, we'll show you one more way
to test your game in real time and
improve it.